je sais que tu passes ta famille et
moi-même oui bonjour monsieur ya une
commission à vous faire de la parution
harry lequel henry le petit ou le grand
les moyens au fait je vois le bal hakim
un costume et une cravate et il est
toujours une chemise lui non le gland
qui met toujours des pantalons avec des
pulls en versant des eaux salées je vois
le matelassier tapissier décorateur non
lui disent qu'ils arriveraient papier ça
y est je ne remets
ouais celui qu'un mari et son frère et
sa soeur avec le fils mouliot non lui la
manier son frère avec la fille à ma
sauce arrivé seul et je vois qu'ici est
celui qui était venu en communion de
maurice aux deux fils à ses roueries nom
à lui l'année pas pu venir il avait
envoyé son frère aîné où le cadet les
moyens celui qui le met jamais et qui
demande elle est bénie italien gagnait
20 kw à celui qui s'est associé avec
gifi tholot un marchand des quatre
saisons mais nord il avait pris la féra
son compte avec blood comme comptable
long de leurs représentants des vins et
spiritueux non blondes dans l'ancien
chanteur pascal miralles trucage
miralles miralles des ptt ou morales la
balance qui tapait la chorba catella
boscacci solivérès la grande brasserie
il râle est le beau frère à cailloux qui
faisait les noces et banquets lequel
faye où le père ou le fils aîné veut une
veuve qu'il était toujours chez levi
levin les villes et villes et vie c'est
un nom qui me dit quelque chose
lequel les villes et des qui travaillait
chez boris sont polis mais boîtier ou
bien évident que faisait ici au palais
de justice sont les villes les victimes
c'est le tailleur chez still des
ralentis apprentis et vidal d'alger
connu vidalon un ancien joueur de
football qui faisait hier matin qui se
reposaient l'après midi et qu'il avait
pas l'entraînement le soir mais non
menace qui pesait taxi vidal obstacle si
vous confondez pas avec charlie driguet
ce que son père il avait une droguerie
revenus de là vous auriez à côté de cela
le boulanger mais non vidal qui faisait
le taxi qui la donne 400 can 404 bleue
ou noire et grise avec le toit bleu bleu
clair ou bleu foncé le ciel qui tirait
sur le verbe barré voulu oui pouvaient
ils avaient des enfants
oui de un gars une fille une fille si
une fille chrome en effet une fille on
l'appelait la fée vidal elle était
mariée oui avec qui avec nations
arrivées motion rim
c'est lui qui m'en voir
riton qui faisait contrôleurs au cinéma
rialto s'il faut dire d'avancé
bon alors qu'est-ce qui me vu des voix
la wii devrait savoir si vous avez connu
un homme et dupond dupont oui alors que
lequel dupont celui qui faisait glaciers
au bar à saintes est lui qui travaillait
cadre de chez zéro mais reste celui qui
était contre leur fait faire à celui qui
était contrôleur au t1 celui qui
travaille avec gaspard boujut pas celui
qui t'a pas ce gouvernement y avait un
job